this is a production of Cornell
University okay so thank you for having
me I haven't spoken to this seminar
series before so it's really nice to be
here faces and introduce you to our
program so today I want to cover quite a
large number of things so that's gonna
give me the high five if I'm going too
long but I want to set the stage in case
you're not familiar with global data on
where we are with climate change and how
that affects agriculture and then I want
to introduce you to the work we've been
doing since 2015 with the climate smart
farming program and that includes
stakeholder research and engagement so I
am trained as a social scientist my PhD
is in global environmental politics
which you could ask me how I got to this
position it was a long circuitous route
but I'm really happy to be here I love
working with farmers and agriculture at
the intersection of agriculture and
environment um then I'll talk about our
resources I'll introduce you to the
decision tools that we have developed
and talked about the outreach that we do
and then I want to take this to sort of
connect it to the work that johannes and
I do by talking about what we do at the
cup and how climate smart agriculture is
a term that's really gaining traction
globally it's critically important that
Cornell stay involved with this and I
also want to acknowledge that I'm part
of a team you'll see the team up here so
this work I'm presenting it but it's
really that I helped facilitate a lot of
the work that goes on at Cornell and
this is not just my output it's a whole
team so Brian Belcher is one of our
programmers an amazing computer
programmer with a master's degree in
atmospheric science and he was going to
be here today to help talk about the
tools but he is sick so so to give you a
little bit of background this if you
haven't seen the
data this is the global temperature
change data showing here global change
in Fahrenheit from before 1900 up past
2000 and if you saw the New York Times
article recently last year was one of
the warmest years on record our earth's
temperature globally in 2018 was more
than 1.8 degrees Fahrenheit warmer or
above average temperature of the
previous since the 19th century and so
we also we talked about in terms of
climate change because it's not only
temperature change but impacts like
increasing severity of drought so this
shows data of the change in the drought
severity index the Palmer drought
severity index from 1900 to 20 2002
areas of the globe that are more dry are
getting drier and projections are that
that will be the trend so we in the
Northeast are actually very fortunate um
this is one of the things that when I go
out and do very frequent talks with
agriculture groups farmers this is the
thing that they are noticing the most
and that I talk about in terms of they
often don't make the connection that
this is related to changing climate so
we see an observed trend in these very
very heavy rainfall events from 1950 to
2000 to 2012 this is happening all over
the United States but the most
pronounced effect is in the northeastern
US where we're getting these very heavy
downpours and then
shows you data from the last National
Climate Assessment that shows that in
the Northeast we're seeing this
frost-free season length lengthening by
10 days so these changes all affect
farmers and where we are projected to go
this projections of climate depend on
the emissions that we all emit globally
and so this is just a middle emission
scenario there is a high emission
scenario and a very very efficient low
emission scenario even with a high
emission scenario or a middle emission
scenario we are going to be warming on
average we are expected to increase by 2
to 13 degrees Fahrenheit by the end of
the century depending on what we as
humans do and so this is in really one
of the most critical issues globally
that we face and especially for farmers
so agriculture you can think about it
that it's really one of the most unique
sectors and one of the most challenging
to address and that's why when I talk
about global policy it's been very hard
to address agriculture within the United
Nations Framework Convention because
it's so challenging because it's it's an
economic sector farmers need to be
profitable but they are also globally
one of the largest oops one of the
largest shoots
producers of greenhouse gas emissions so
this is local data from the IPCC that
agriculture forestry and land use
represents 24 percent of global
greenhouse gas emissions but at the same
time they are one of the most vulnerable
sectors that is really impacted by
climate change so this is a brand new
FAO report from 2018 that shows the
increase in these annual economic
damages to agriculture from
climate-related disasters we know that
one disaster
or one weather event is not climate
change but we know that these extreme
events are increasing with climate
change
so from 14 billion in the last decade
we've gone to a hundred billion dollars
annually and if another way of thinking
about this is in our own region we have
we know farmers are experiencing
challenges and are expected to increase
experience these challenges in the
future including the increase in extreme
weather events flooding and then
short-term droughts on the other extreme
high temperature stress few pests and
diseases but of all you saw that picture
of the globe of where it's going to get
more dry and if we think about dr. Toby
alts work looking at projections for
very long term droughts in the
southeastern United States then if we
think about where we are in the
Northeast we have opportunities
potentially if we manage our water
resources well we're also closely linked
to 22 percent of the population and
markets in in New York and the Northeast
so we could be producing more products
to make up for losses in other areas and
so this is the latest National Climate
Assessment that just came out even in
the Trump administration this came out
talking about the effects on agriculture
and I I won't read it but you can go and
find the link there so with that as a
background
the Cornell Institute for climate smart
solutions was formed in 2013 really to
focus on agriculture we did change our
name to be able to work on communities
very related to agriculture and we are
based we're working on facilitating
research helping pull together large
grant proposals that get submitted to
USDA or NSF and there's a really huge
capacity here at Cornell when we think
about it there are more than a hundred
and fifty researchers at Cornell working
on some aspects related to climate
change so all of all the global
universities I think we are one of the
strongest in this area and we should
seize this strength
so this is our core team here we sit
over in Rice Hall our faculty advisors
are here we have three postdocs one
Danielle is full-time with us and then
Carlos and Demetri sit mostly in E is
and work with Toby but they work on
tools that are on the climate start
farming website and then quite uniquely
I was on the phone with our extension
team this morning these are an
incredible resource for New York State
we have the only climate smart farming
team in the country and these are folks
that are out working in the region's
kitty has a PhD Elizabeth is brand new
to the team an amazing resource and they
can really connect us to what's
happening on the farms and what farmers
think and are they going to be using
these tools or what's the most important
tool that we could develop and I'll talk
about some of the resources we've worked
on with them so I mention at the
beginning that I am a social scientist
and so part of the research that I do
with others here to contribute to the
climate smart farming program is to take
a look at what stakeholders in this case
farmers or extension or consultants
think about climate change what are they
doing to adapt what are they doing to
mitigate what are the barriers that they
experience and we know that a
stakeholder is defined as any citizen or
group partially potentially affected by
or having a vested interest and so I
think this is really critically
important I love working at Cornell
because we have the capacity to work
with interdisciplinary teams probably
more than any other University when I
talked to my colleagues at American
University and they and they understand
what we can do here that I get to work
with Matt on a proposal or call him up
and ask him for input but I can work on
the social science it's really really
powerful and it's critically important
because if if we're just developing fact
sheets and tools but we don't
no if farmers even want them or what
their level of computer usage is or are
they going to use them they're not
likely to use them and I have some data
a little bit depressing data that shows
that quite well so the things that the
idea here is that we would be doing we
are doing cutting-edge climate change
research here at Cornell we are
developing decision tools for a long
time starting and work in this
department with adapt gun and other
tools we do have very strong abstention
programming and so we can engage farmers
and understand what they are looking for
and then improve research and the
extension that we're doing so some of
the social science research that we've
been involved with we did a
meta-analysis that looked at all the
literature on climate change in
agriculture from 1997 to 2016 and
published that in this article in Weyers
climate change we've conducted focus
groups in New York and Pennsylvania
that's been published and then we are
working on a publication that looks at
dairy producers views and actions in
Wisconsin in New York that was part of
the dairy cap project um and then we've
started to do some work in surveys now
that we have really some in-depth
knowledge we can do more broad scale
surveys so we've done a convenient
sample survey at Empire Farm days over
two years we've done an online random
sample survey of New York farmers we did
not get a great response rate because it
was a an electronic survey so if you
think about 32,000 farmers in New York
State we did not get a good response
rate so we and that's in part because
farmers are less likely to fill out an
electronic survey so we're planning to
revise the survey and do a mailed survey
it's much more expensive to do it that
way but we're going to hire a company to
help with that and then as an example we
can do farm visits and with an intern
that we had a Cooperative Extension
pharming intern I'm an awesome
undergraduate Tyler Brewer went out and
he worked in Madison County all last
summer with Sarah ficken and they went
out to over 30 farms and talked about
the impacts that farmers are
experiencing and what are the adaptation
practices they are working on so just
some general too much text on this side
but some general findings from our
social science aspects are that the key
impacts in the Northeast are things that
we would expect more farmers are
noticing more extreme weather flooding
are the two things they talk about most
changes in seasons and pests and we know
that the majority of farmers believe the
climate is changing so even today
talking to our extension team they know
that their colleagues are reluctant to
talk up to farmers about this issue but
we know that farmers agree the climate
is changing so I keep trying to talk to
you
our extension team and Extension say
don't be afraid to address this issue
talk about it in terms of increased
flooding or talked about it in terms of
resiliency or energy savings through
mitigation because they know that your
climate is changing don't shy away from
this science-based topic all day and
then from the focus groups we know that
although farmers are concerned about
climate impacts especially in New York
State when we've done the focus groups
they are also much more concerned about
these other issues and so what we see is
that climate change just adds one more
layer of stress if you think about the
dairy industry and profitability right
now climate change is not their type
priority but when they get hit by a five
inch rainfall event then yeah they are
suffering
more than they would have been so if we
can talk to them about adaptation
practices that they're already doing or
they could do slowly over time that's a
good way of framing it and just
very recent findings from our pilot
surveys in terms of climate change 68%
of the farmers that responded we're
concerned are very concerned about
drought and about increases in extreme
precipitation 64% of the adaptation
practices that they said they are
adopting many are using diversified
rotation soil health less so reduced
tillage and when we asked about tools or
weather forecasts most farmers 63% do
not use any apps or smartphones or
mobile devices to inform their
management decisions so that's pretty
depressing when we asked about the
specific online weather and climate
resources they are using the Farmers
Almanac which is not that accurate so we
have a lot of work to do to get farmers
to really understand these tools and
understand how they are helpful so with
that I'll introduce you to the program
and I have materials in the back some
fact sheets and business cards you could
take a bunch and hand them out if you
work with farmers so really we're
providing of one place for resources we
have some videos of farmers talking
about what they have experienced we have
links to our extension team and the site
actually got above 3000 web web hits a
month recently so we see that the usage
is climbing which is great so there's an
example of a video that we captured with
the help of undergrads is this local
farmer maybe you know him Toro Schnur
and he says in the video a normal season
doesn't seem like it happens anymore
it's either really dry or really wet we
got five inches of rain in an hour and a
half and I had a lot of soil loss and he
was almost in tears at this point
it was like apocalyptic so please check
out this video and others not all the
farmers that we talked to would agree
that there taking the actions that they
are because of climate change some of
the apple farmers in western New York
are there's a net zero farm and he did
not do that for climate change he did
that because he wanted to have control
over his energy costs um so I would say
maybe that doesn't matter
he's a NetZero farm and we should share
his story and get other farmers to
understand that they can do the same
thing so this is our extension team
again and the idea here is that very we
don't have the funds nor would these
experts have the time to work on climate
change solely for 100% of their job and
I actually think it's more important
that they incorporate this into the work
that they're doing so kiddi just told me
on the call that she did two talks last
week that explained the cover crop tool
and the growing degree day tool so
they're incorporating what their climate
and the resources and tools into their
work with farmers and so these are the
resources our undergrad is working on
getting new fact sheets from Peter wood
buried up here on mitigation and there
are a lot of things up there so I'm
assuming you all have a good
understanding of this I'm not going to
explain this this would be something
that I would talk about with farmer
audiences but when we do we need to
think about mitigation which is reducing
emissions and adaptation for a long time
in climate science in policy world
policymakers didn't want to go to work
on adaptation because it would be like
admitting defeat and if we start working
on adaptation we're not going to reduce
emissions I think there's a definite
change where as we know even if we
mitigate we're going to have to adapt so
Peter is the expert in the room on much
more than I
on these things and there are tools on
the website that we are linking to and
much more it could be done at Cornell to
find out if farmers are actually using
these tools to what extent are they
doing greenhouse gas audits on their
farm but we don't have the resources to
do that yet the other term as I
mentioned is adaptation and there are a
lot of examples of some great resources
out there one of which came from the
USDA climate hubs and it's this
adaptation resources book workbook
that's now online if you look at it it's
pretty straightforward it's identifying
a process that farmers can use to look
at what hap what's happening on their
farms specifically and then evaluate the
different management options they have
and then adaptation approaches and then
monitor and monitor and review if
they're making changes so an example of
that these are the key strategies that
that adaptation resource is highlighting
sustaining fundamental functions of soil
and water so protecting water quality
improving soil health and then all the
way down to looking at infrastructure
what we found we actually did an online
climate smart farming course and had
some farmers use this workbook and it's
not that easy to use and it's pretty
complicated it's 100 pages long and so
our team thought that it would be much
more useful there wasn't a resource like
this that's a short very factual
assessed short assessment of what are
the six key things that you may already
be doing as a farmer but that will help
you increase resiliency and so this is
one of the sheets I have in the back our
team worked on this it took us longer
than we thought because we didn't want
the language to be vague we wanted it to
be really specific
to what farmers could actually do and
that helped we do this so I want to turn
now to the decision tools that are on
our website and we are really fortunate
at Cornell to have the Northeast
Regional Climate Center here on the 11th
floor that's led by dr. art de Gaetano
and they maintain all of the climate
data for the northeastern United States
for NOAA and their the purpose of the in
center there's a center in different
regions this is the Northeast region is
to make climate data available for
stakeholders to use the data and
understand the climate and how climate
is changing and so by working with NRCC
we've worked to make some very specific
web-based decision tools that can be
used anywhere in the northeastern United
States from Maine down to West Virginia
for free any one of you if you live in
Ithaca you can enter your address and on
the left hand side of the tool is where
you enter your user information there's
some user inputs on the on the water
tool you enter what kind of soil you
have what type of crop you're growing
and then you get some pretty specific
information about where you are in the
season based on the different tool so
the amazing thing about these tools
there is a complimentary system called
NOAA which is based on whether small
weather stations and data from these
small stations that farmers have
purchased and put on their farm
they cost about a thousand dollars and
there's a not a large network of them
now
but if you're not near one of those
stations you're kind of out of luck in
using their tools and so this is a
really nice complementary system so this
shows you the tools that we have its
climate smart farming org and the first
tool is a really
powerful growing degree day calculator
the way that we talk about the fact that
this one is different from many others
out there is that it's using its
updating on a daily basis of data
whereas many if you looked in a a group
or above 50 years ago and looked at the
charts for growing degree day
calculations it was using a static
calculation and it might have been
updated and some of the calculators out
there use a static day that's 15 years
so this is updating on a daily basis and
you can see here the ranges this is
showing
ethic of New York you would put any
address in the northeast year and you
would put your planting date or put
March if you have one at whatever date
if you have a perennial crop and then
you choose your GDD base and it would
show you where you are in the season if
you look at the tool right now brian has
not hit the switch to start this growing
season although we just got an email
from a farmer in Virginia asking like
it's already warming it's already the
spring season so we're gonna think about
maybe starting the tool earlier but you
can go back and look at last year's data
and all the way back I think very far
back many years back so as a planning
tool a farmer can look at what happened
last year or the year before when they
planted what date they planted and Kitty
O'Neil and Elizabeth are planning to do
really short little video clips talk
about four farmers that this is a really
it's an agronomic tool so you if they
can use this to do some planning
decisions about exactly when to plant or
different different crops that they may
plant with different growing degree days
where were they last year where was the
end of the season and makes some much
more informed decisions so this is
showing you the period of record here is
the black and this was 2016 this is the
growing degree day a cumulation up to
that date we have a forecast here which
farmers really like it looks at the next
five six days and then you can see that
it's also just an educational tool
because this is the 30 year normal and
this is the 15 year average and
oftentimes this isn't this image image
isn't showing this but oftentimes this
growing new gray accumulation for a year
will be like way above here I should
have used a different screenshot so any
questions about that
tool so the other tool that we developed
really based on Kitty's input of working
with farmers is that we need a cover
crops scheduler because oftentimes
what's happening is that we have a
unusually wet or cold spring and farmers
can't get into the field to plant and
then they're trying to make a decision
on whether they can get that cover crop
established in time to where it would be
enough of a profitable venture by the
end of the season and so we have three
cover crops in there now that's the data
that we have working with researchers on
campus if we had other data we could
populate this more Brian also added this
feature with farmer input which so shows
the last first and last freeze dates
which is really helpful for farmers and
then another tool that we have is this
water deficit calculator and I don't
know what the screenshot is showing here
okay it's showing 2016 and you enter
your soil water capacity and your crop
what are you growing when did you plant
it and whether or not you've irrigated
if you have not irrigated you just leave
this plank and you will see the chance
that you have or might have severe plant
stress based on that crop and it does
have a forecast on there as well so this
was a tool that was really useful when
we had the very dry period a few years
ago so the newest tool we've developed
is called climate change in my County
and it was a conception for a long time
we weren't really sure how maybe
farmers are not the most interested in
this but policymakers would be or
agencies county agencies Farm Bureau so
when you go into this
tool it's you would come into the
Northeast right off the bat and it would
show you what is though general warming
in each County what's the warming data
and you can see that for the with the
exception of these few counties
unfortunately down here in more
conservative West Virginia that wouldn't
would would not want that data but other
than that it's been a warming trend and
then what you can do is over here you
can pick your county and these are the
choices here if you want to see average
temperature high temperature days with
highs above 90 degrees growing season
length and then total precipitation
extreme precipitation and then you can
also look at the climate change
projections for those temperature or
precipitation so this is showing you
that the projected increase in
temperature through the end of the
century based on climate models the data
that we have through the Northeast
Regional Climate Center showing in this
county we are projected to get a lot
warmer and it's nice because all of
these dots are the observed data and
there is a trend of a significant trend
in warming and then it shows where we
would be by the end of the century so
this is a long-term planning tool and
that's really where the Institute has
been trying to get is we can tell you
how things are more variable we can give
you more accurate information help you
with specific planting cropping
decisions but you can also think long
term the same thing with rainfall like
should I start thinking about irrigation
or or tile drainage if I know that this
is the trend so we do have done more and
more training and outreach these are two
events that we did Twilight meetings on
farms in Madison County and Oneida
County last year which were great
because we
had the soil lab there but we also were
able to demonstrate the tools and this
is Kevin gun oh he's a AG expansion
specialist so she he was explaining
exactly how you could use that going to
breed a calculator with planting
decisions in mind and we have a Wi-Fi
device so it was live people could put
their address in and so I want to switch
just for the last couple minutes and
talk connect this to where we are
globally and as Matt mentioned I've gone
as a trained in global policy my love is
to work globally and connect that to the
local level this past year I taught
global environmental climate science and
policy with Natalie Mahal and we took 17
students to the UN climate change talks
yo.hannes went on the delegation to
Poland in December and when we're at the
cop meetings we have a exhibit of
Cornell's research climate research and
we talk about what we're doing here at
Cornell and we have videos and I there's
a huge interest in climate change in
agriculture and I talk about the tools
that we have and they say can we get
those tools in our country or what are
you doing in Ethiopia and so we know
globally there is a lack of accurate
weather station and climate data there's
a huge need and a huge interest in
digital agriculture and decision support
tools globally they with Cornell's
expertise they could be connected to the
landscape scale and there's a need there
also then to develop similar extension
or training and outreach programs
globally so we've had a lot of interests
we tried developing a proposal for
Pakistan it didn't get funded but the
proposal is still there there's a lot of
interest and connecting that to some of
the work that I do as a social scientist
if we think about policy global climate
change in agriculture policy
there's
policy that takes place at the national
level through this United Nations
Framework Convention and every single
country that came to the Paris agreement
in 2015 had to come with a national plan
of how they were going to reduce
emissions and also many of them included
adaptation and of those probably 60% of
those included climate smart agriculture
in their plan
so they especially countries in
developing developing countries are very
keen to work on to get resources and
technology and get help with adaptation
in agriculture and then if we think
about policy you have to think about
what's the national government policy
and how is that global policy going to
be translated to the national level and
then down to the local level and so I
could give you a whole talk on the Paris
agreement but basically it's been signed
by 184 parties and the u.s. is still a
signatory to this agreement and every
party with the exception of the United
States every country in the world is
party to this agreement now is agreeing
to the goal that we will reduce
emissions to keep our global temperature
at well below two degrees Celsius with
the intention to keep it below 1.5 and
if you heard the climate talked last
week from Natalie Mahal she was a lead
author on this one point five degree
report from the IPCC that looked at
whether or not this is even possible and
so if you think about this global policy
all these countries have agreed to work
on this then how does that translate to
the work we need to do on agriculture
and so there is a new process that was
agreed to you at last year's cop called
the koruna be a joint work program on
agriculture it's something where I went
to these two track these meetings tried
my best to track these meetings for the
past two years and it
basically that the implementation
committee in the UN and the the
Technology Committee are working
together just to think about what are
the global challenges for addressing
climate change in agriculture and what
are the needs and at the last cop in
Poland there was an all-day workshop
with 11 agencies reporting on what they
are doing on climate smart agriculture
and the United States had representation
there some farm bureau and some other AG
agencies were represented there to try
and track this a key summary from a
group called CGIAR is that these
conferences are crucial to further
climate action on agriculture but
progress has been slow over the past 24
years and so we need to think about at
Cornell but also at all these different
levels how can we complement the
negotiations with initiatives to speed
up adaptation and mitigation in
agriculture and I'll end up the talk by
talking about this concept of climate
smart agriculture how many of you are
familiar with it Matt and ok a good
number it's really came out in the last
few years as a way to advance policy and
work on the ground with farmers and it's
really based on three pillars of looking
at adaptation mitigation and sustainably
increasing productivity to reduce global
food insecurity and it came about in
2009 there's been some controversy about
this term even on our campus where
people have asked me are you sure you
want to work on that because it the
controversy is that the term wasn't
well-defined before the concepts we're
not well defined before this got put out
by the FAO and some believe that
global corporations like Monsanto will
have undue influence and be pushing this
agenda to push one agenda where they're
still conflicting ideas about what is
the best way to mitigate climate change
or what's the best way to adapt to
climate change in agriculture I really
feel like it's a useful concept and a
useful process there is a Global
Alliance for climate smart agriculture
that Cornell is a part of and I try to
help them as much as possible it's just
a voluntary network and they share
information and share resources
including with businesses because they
argue that if we don't get companies on
board and be talking with them and
farmer organizations and we're not going
to really make progress we can't just be
working on small-scale agriculture we
have to work on all types of agriculture
and so this is some work that I've done
and I guess I would end up talk by
saying there is a lot of work going on
globally on climate smart agriculture
there's a need to scale up we hear this
term all the time
globally there's a need to scale up
adaptation at the same time as
mitigation and sustainable
intensification but there's different
interests and it's really complicated we
need to strengthen capacity and
extension and research globally so some
key takeaways from the talk and then I'm
happy to answer questions is that
climate change is already affecting
farmers in New York State and globally
it's interesting when you go to the cop
and you actually talk to a farmer from
Africa and I'll ask them what what are
you experiencing and they'll say extreme
rainfall events I'll say Wow
you see some of the same challenges
globally farmers acknowledge they're
experiencing climate change you just
need to figure out the best way to
engage them on this topic um we need
social science is really important we
need to understand what farmers think
about this issue what tools and
practices they're using
what they have available to them and
what they can do what they need to adapt
and mitigate the climate and agriculture
tools can help farmers make much more
informed decisions and I would say I
hear this again and again extension
globally and in New York State is really
critical and there needs to be more
funding and support for extension um and
the last point I would make is that I
would love to see more engagement
globally I would love to see Cal say
this is a priority we need to be engaged
globally on climate change in
agriculture is something Johannes has
really been talking about for a long
time so that's
[Applause]
hi hi so here's a bill in front of the
New York State Legislature or Carbon
Farming just reproduced with a bunch of
new sponsors on it and the plan would be
to subsidize farmers for the economic
value of the carbon sequestered by
various types of our farm practices that
would be a tax credit so just comments
on with your stability with the hill
weather I mean agate markets are
supposed to come up with this model
which I think they're probably not quite
up to that task you know given their
presence that thing but just thoughts
about that model and whether the science
is there to make this ready for
primetime and whether they contact you
without I have heard about the bill
filtering through I don't know the
prospects that it's gonna get passed
this year but it is something that we
should be tracking I didn't mention it
but there is a New York State climate
resilient farm initiative and most of
that funding goes to Ag and markets to
put technology in place like manure
covers through the AG Environment
Program AEM there has been a little bit
of research funding that came here so I
haven't really tracked that bill other
than I knew it was out there yeah they
counted for coming to talk to us I'd
like your opinion on the disconnection
from the aims or units in your program
and some of the additional
recommendations that are coming on
University that are really countered to
that notably our recommendation for late
I didn't manifest they're not adaptive
they're not mitigative they allow for
highly excessive rates been warned that
management fertilizer rate implications
on carbon sequestration batches oxide
emissions and so there's really this
contradiction between what progressive
programs like yours are trying to do and
what we stand for as an institution in
terms of I'm aware of the of the
challenge what do you think we could do
to bridge that the best ways to get
farmers to I don't know the best tools
and information well there's a lot of
things that we sort of fish you promote
guidelines and and maybe it's time to is
we have programs like this which I think
it's great and I support it's time to
kind of revisit what we are otherwise
recommending and somebody's recommending
that regulations are highly updated and
and so you know we have very limited
credibility on the one hand yes
so my question is I'm one guy he was
born 100 percent agency in regards to
each development these payments are in
schools and their ability to use them on
their part day vibrates have a hundred
percent changes either totally in charge
of what they're doing they're giving him
our mercy system by its own forces their
hand decision I pushed him on that
spectrum where he ever thought so that's
a great question no one's ever asked me
that before so what what are you
thinking of the decisions that are not
that they can't because of the system
are you thinking because of seed that
they have to buy or like when I think
about dairy farms right now the price is
so low you need to produce mill work not
to stay solvent which then leads to
ensuring the center of sure so okay so I
guess I would say to that that this is a
challenging time to talk about climate
change in this for the dairy industry
right now because they are not going to
be able to take make large investments
they just don't have the money to do
that but I would I would say that it's
an additional stress or to them and if
they're already doing things like
they're already plant thinking about
l'hotel or they're thinking about soil
health they're many of the progressive
farmers are doing a lot of these
practices
or not new then making them aware that
over time if they do these things or
they prioritize if they know that
flooding in this area of the farm is
where they're getting hit the most then
they prioritize adaptations that would
help with that
right did I answer try to answer your
question okay
yes kindness but I see from your
presentation that extension is pretty
involved where you're targeting
individual parts and introducing them to
these tools are helping them we use
digital I that have been developed
collection that it's going into unlike
how much work would you say is brilliant
to looking at larger organizations and
people or policies that mean a great
point great point I mean if I had more
time and I am a policy person so I
understand that we need to be thinking
about how do we interact with Farm
Bureau or how do we make changes as
cornell to the farm bill that just got
passed or we think about state and
national policy the way we've tried to
do that is just stay engaged with new
york state agencies and let them know
the resources we have but we were not
being asked to do Policy Analysis maybe
Peter is or others but we could be doing
more in that area as Cornell
yeah we're out of time but well they may
be interested in protecting the land but
they own very small plots so it is a
challenge and that's why I think we
can't just have these global initiatives
we need to look at what every country is
doing - what if what are they proposing
for adaptation and climate change and if
you look at it it's often very vague and
then even if they have a national policy
is that actually getting implemented
with input from farmers on the ground so
we have Humphrey fellows here and we had
a really interested fellow who is now
the climate change in agriculture focal
point / Punjab Pakistan and she's on
Facebook and she posted that they have a
brand new CSA plan and her idea she
wanted these decision tools to be put in
place with a plan that every farmer the
government just paid every farmer to get
a smartphone even if they're really
small-scale farmers and so we could be
doing alerts we could be sending out
alerts of when they might see a pasture
when they might need to irrigate and so
I think people are thinking about it
it's a really big challenge and
something exciting to think about
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu